it is absolutely shocking to me that you  think that you can turn up here this  afternoon with a mess that your party  has made to the budgets of this country  to the reputation of this country around  the world that you promise those people  that there will be more to come and you  think you turn up here this afternoon  and claim some sort of moral High Ground  what sort of world do you belong in  [Music]  yeah and I understand that the arguments  and the feelings run high on these  issues from a variety of perspectives  um I understand some of the shouting  taking place but I won't have people  pointing in anger and gesticulating in  Anger at other people can we just take a  moment just to calm down